Evet ben yine geldim neredeyiz bugün
Periyodik tabloda yer bulmadan
bahsedeceğiz elektron dizilimlerini
yaptık şimdi bu elektron dizilimlerini
kullanarak Periyodik tabloda yer nasıl
bulunur periyodik tablo Nasıl bir şeydi
şöyle özelliklerinden falan bahsedelim
istersen hazırsan başlayalım periyodik
tablo ul Bu nasıl bir şekil bak garip
garip periyodik tablolar var karşımızda
böyle bir periyodik tablo yapmış birisi
mesela şuradan başlatmış Yani insana
eziyet çektirilecek de böyle mi
çektirilir ya şöyle diyor bak Buradan
başladı 1A grubu burası diyor Sonra 2A
grubu Sonra işte buraya geliyor
lantanitler falan Sonra B grupları
geliyor 3A 4A 5A tekrar başa dönüyoruz
falan diyor da yani niye eziyet etmiş
kendine bak başka bir periyodik tablo
daha var burada yine başlangıç noktası
bura alkali metallerin olduğu yer
başlatmış sonra şurası 2A grubu
elementleri demiş Sonra gelmiş buraya
işte lantanit aktinitleri koymuş Sonra B
gruplarını koymuş gelmiş sonraki İşte o
3A 4A 5A 6a 7A 8A diye gelmiş bu
merkezden başlayarak böyle helezon
şeklinde gitmiş bu şekilde bir periyodik
tablo da yapılmış mesela zamanında ama
periyodik tablo dediğimizde aklımıza iki
tane abimiz geliyor birisi işte şu nur
yüzlü abimiz Dimitri
mendelevium gelecek kişilerdir Aslında
son zamanlara doğru bunlar Eee bayağı
bir çalışmış Dimitri mendeleev mesela
elementleri atom kütlesine göre
sıralamış bak bu atom kütlesine ve
benzer özelliklerine göre sıralıyor ve
bir periyodik tablo buluyor Ne zamanmış
işte 1869 yılında böyle bir çalışma
yapıyor Hatta aynı dönemlerde loter meer
diye birisi var O da çok benzer bir
periyodik tablo yapıyor Eee böyle ilginç
bir şekilde ikisi denk geliyor
birbirlerinden habersiz benzer bir
periyodik tablo bulmuşlar Mesela işte bu
elementleri atom kütlesine göre dizdiğim
şöyle bir şey oluyor aynı kutuya birden
fazla element koyduğu da oluyor çünkü
atom kütlesi aynı olan elementler denk
geliyor bazı kutular boş kalıyor Çünkü o
zamana kadar keşfedilmiş element sayısı
az E bundan dolayı bazı kutucuklar boş
kalıyor böyle çeşitli çalışmalar
yaptığında ilginç bir başarısı var ki o
da şudur Periyodik tabloda boş bıraktığı
yerlerdeki bir tanesini özellikle
silisyumun altında bir boşluk var Eka
silisyum di diyor Böyle Soru işareti
koyuyor diyor ki buraya bir element
gelecek diyor bu elementin diyor işte
kütlesi 72 falan olacak yanlış
hatırlamıyorsa öyle bir şeydi kütlesi şu
olacak diyor yoğunluğu şöyle olacak
böyle olacak sayıyor yani daha element
bulunmadan o özel özelliklerdeki
değişimi o kadar güzel irdeliyor ki
oradaki elementin özelliklerini
keşfediyor ve o element keşfedildiğinde
ki O birazdan söyleyeceğim germanyum
elementi keşfedildiğinde çoğu dediği
gibi çıkıyor mesela çok da ilginç bir
durumdur O yüzden zeki bir insandır
kendisine saygım sonsuzdur Mesela bu
adamın hatası yok mu var atom kütlesine
göre dizmek en büyük hatası Çünkü atom
kütlesine göre dizdiğim aynı kutuya
birden fazla element yazmak zorunda
kalıyorsun işte atom kütlesini dikkate
alması hatasıdır atom numarası yani
Proton Proton sayısını dikkate almaması
Tabii ki onun eksikliğidir Ama tabii
kütle numarasının o zaman biliniyor da
proton sayısı ile ilgili daha böyle bir
e durumlar karışık sonra Henry mosley
gelecek o şeyi halledecek elementlerin
atom numarasını böyle hassasiyetle bir
özel Spektrum işlemiyle X X ışını
spektrumu işlemiyle halledecek dostum
İşte bak o söylediğim olay ekas silisyum
diyor silisyum la aynı yerde gibi bir
anlamı var Sonra element keşfediliyor
1886 yılında germanyum olarak
keşfediliyor bak tahminlerine bak
tahmini kütle numarası 72 yani atom
kütlesi 72 ne çıkıyor 72. küsur işte
yoğunluğu 5,5 diyor 5 5.3 falan çıkıyor
E diyor ki erime noktası yüksek ya tam
bir değer vermiyor ama 938 gibi bir
değer çıkıyor rengi tutturuyor
özelliğinin bazik olduğunu keşfediyor
Daha ne yapsın bu adam Yani mesela
klorla oluşturduğu bileşiğin formülüne
kadar giriyor yani bayağı bir şey
keşfediyor ve çıkıyor sonra geliyor
Henry mosley Henry mosley X ışını
deneyleriyle X ışını spektrumu dene
deneyleriyle elementlerin atom
numaralarını hassasiyetle belirliyor
yani Proton sayısını belirliyor ve şunu
fark ediyor her elementin proton sayısı
birbirinden farklı Ee o zaman diyor Biz
diyor periyodik tabloyu yaparken Proton
sayısını kullanalım aynı olan yok Nasıl
olsa aynı kutucuğa birden fazla denk
gelemeyecek diyor buna göre bir
periyodik tablo yapıyor yani Henry moos
elementleri atom numarasına yani Proton
sayısına göre ve benzer özelliklerine
göre sıralıyor kimyasal özelliklerine
göre ve karşımıza İşte o klasik
periyodik tablo çıkıyor işte o Periyodik
tabloda Şurada şöyle ek ekrana sığdır
alım Evet şu an sığdı mesela değil mi
Evet sığdı periyodik tablo bunu
keşfediyor mesela Şu alttaki iki sırayı
da en alttaki iki sırayı da daha sonra
1952 yılında glenn seaborg diye bir adam
var o buraya yerleştiriyor Şimdi burada
tabii ki şunu söylemek lazım Henry
mosley Henry mosley ile ilgili çok şey
duymuşsundur anlatılan çok yerde
anlatmışlardır bunu şöyle söyleyeyim
Henry mosley e 20 küsur yaşlarındaydı
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam Eee sanki bir o
zaman görmüşüm gi anlattım da yani Yok e
Böyle aklında kalmış şeye Katılıyor
savaşa Katılıyor o zamanlar işte 1 Dünya
Savaşı falan Eee Bu da savaşa Katılıyor
bu İngiliz İngiliz subayı olarak
Katılıyor Eee ve geldiği yerde Çanakkale
yani Şansına bak Çanakkale'ye geliyor
şöyle bir şey vardır Bak bizim millet
bilim insanına saygılıdır Allah için bak
saygılıdır şu var vatanını savunan bilim
insanına daha çok saygılıdır ama
başkasının vatanını ele geçirmeye gelene
e kusura bakmasın Yani saygı da
göstermez hakkını verir y lar bizden bir
tanesi söylenen işte bir tane sniper'ın
vurduğuna dair bir şey söylenir de Eee
doğrusunu tam bilmiyoruz ama bu kadar
zeki bir insan Keşke savaşa katılmasıdır
da daha güzel şeyler bulsaydı ama
yapacak bir şey yok Biz de kendimizi
savunuyoruz yani gariban e kötü yola
gitmiş Neyse yapacak bir şey yok şimdi
bakın dönelim periyodik tablomu Bak bu
Periyodik tabloda görüyor musun şöyle
sıra sıra yazmış işte birinci periyot
sonra ikinci periyot Şurada da
özelliklerin nerede ne olduğunu
gösteriyor şöyle yaklaşım istersen
genellikle Hani bu üst üst tarafa yazmış
Ne bu Proton sayısını gösteriyor atom
numarasını gösteriyor başka elementin
simgesini yazmış elementin adını
göstermiş ortalama atom kütlesini
göstermiş Bunlar en basit Periyodik
tabloda olması gereken şeyler ama
genellikle Tabii ki Proton sayısını şu
alt şu köşeye yazsak daha da güzel olur
yani gerçek yerine yazsak daha da güzel
olur tabii ki şöyle bir şey var Bak
Periyodik tabloda dikkat ettiysem 1ci
periyotta iki tane element var Aha
burada iki tane element ikinci periyotta
şunlar var şunlar var bak 2 S2 2p 6
gördün mü burada Aslında Buna göre
sıralanmış oluyor 3 periyot 3 S2 3p 6
sonra 4 periyod g bak 4 S1 4 S2 3D 10
Burası 4p bilmem ne İşte hep buna göre
sıralanıyor Gördüğün gibi 2 ve 3
periyotta sekizer element var 4 ve 5
periyotta kaç 18'er element var 6 ve 7
periyotta İsa 32 şer element var çünkü
bunlar da 6 ve 7'de olmakta şöyle şunlar
6 periyotta şu alttakiler ise 7
periyottaki elementlerdir söyleyeceğim
Zaten birazdan özelliklerini kısaca O
zaman şöyle bakarsak Periyodik tabloda
1ci periyotta hidrojen ve helyum var
biri neydi ametal biri de soygazdan 1ci
periyotta metal yokmuş Bak bunu anlamış
olduk ikinci periyotta bak lityum
Berilyum Bor karbon azot oksijen flor ve
neon var hepsinden var yani metal var
ametal var soygaz var bir tek yarı metal
a o da var Yarım metal de var mesela çok
güzel işte 3ün periyotta Aki elementler
burada 4'te Mesela ne oluyor şu Araya
bir şey geliyor bak bunlar B grubu
elementleri ya da yan Grup elementi a
ile bitiren bitenlere ise biz ne diyoruz
baş Grup elementi ya da A grubu
elementleri diyoruz şunlar bak 1A grubu
1 grup 2A Grubu 2 grup 3A grubu 13 Grup
Çünkü araya 10 tane B grubu geliyor 4A
14 Grup 5A 15 Grup bu şekilde gidiyor
Dostum bunlar da zaten 3B 3 grup 4B 4
Grup 3 tane 8B grubu vardır bunlar
aslında yupak göre 8 grup 9 grup ve 10
grup şeklinde söyleniyor bunların
hepsinden bahsedeceğim Bak burada
özellikleri söylüyor periyodik tablodaki
şu yatay sıralara periyot dikey
sütunlara ise Grup ifadesini
kullanıyoruz 7 tane periyot var 18 tane
de grup var Bak şöyle göstereyim 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 tane A grubu 10 tane B grubu var
bu şekilde toplam 18 tane grup var yatay
olarak da şu anda bilmen gereken 7 tane
periyot var başka şöyle bir şey vardır
burada D ile bitenler şunlar mesela s
bloğu elementleri diye geçiyor burada
Mesela P ile bitenler p bloğu
elementleri D ile bitenler D bloğu
elementleri f ile bitenler ise F bloğu
elementleri oluyor bloka benzemiyor gibi
gözüküyor ama bunların hepsi blok blok
Görüyor musun İşte bu ne s bloğu Burası
D bloğu Burası p bloğu Burası da D bloğu
şeklinde gösteriliyor Dostum Evet devam
edelim istersen burada onu söylemiş işte
s ile bitenler s blo P ile bitenler p
blo D ile bitenler D ve f ile biten ler
F bloğu şeklinde söylüyor dediğimiz gibi
a gruplarına baş Grup elementi B
gruplarına ise geçiş elementleri ya da
yan Grup elementleri ismini veriyoruz
söylediğim işte 1ci periyotta 2 element
var 2ci periyotta ve 3 periyotta sekizer
element 4 ve 5de ne var işte 18'er
element 6 ve 7 de 32 şer element
olduğunu söylüyoruz ve bu aşağıdaki
lantanit ve aktinitler ise iç geçiş
elementlerdir Bunlar mesela 6
periyottadır lantanitler bunlarsa 7
periyottadır aktinit Bunlar mesela 4F
ile biter Bunlar da 5f ile biter bunları
da söylemiş olalım F bloğu olduğu için o
zaman şu soruya bakalım Diyor ki modern
periyodik sistemle ilgili yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur proton sayısı esas
alınarak yapılmıştır Evet şu an
günümüzdeki Proton sayısına göre yani
Henry md'nin periyodik tablosu
kullanılmakta 7 periyot 18 gruptan
oluşur Doğru 10 tanesi B grubu neydi 8
tanesi de a grubuyuz baş grup
elementlerinin sayısı yani A grubu
elementlerinin sayısı B grubu
elementlerinin kinden fazladır Hayır bak
şimdi periyodik tabloya görüyor musun A
grubu elementleri şurada şu şekilde ama
B grubu elementleri şunlar ve Şurayı
sayarsan B grubu elementi daha fazladır
O yüzden bu ifade yanlıştır cevap 1 ve 2
oldu yani B seçeneği şu soruya bakalım
periyodik tabloyu vermiş çok güzel diyor
ki periyodik sistemde yerleri belirtilen
elementlerle ilgili yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur demiştim ya şurası s
bloğuyla şöyle p
bloğuyla çizemedim He çizdim diyor ki y
ve z elementleri 4 periyottadır 1
periyot 2 3 4 periyotta y ve z
bulunmakta Doğrudur T elementi baş Grup
elementidir e burası 3A grubunun olduğu
yerde A grubu İsa baş Grup elementidir
Doğrudur Z elementi geçiş metaldir Evet
şu aradakiler de bulunuyorsa geçiş
elementi ya da geçiş metali diyoruz
Doğrudur K elementi diyor ki aktinit
serisidir Hayır önceki lantanit alttaki
aktinit O yüzden bu yanlıştır cevap da e
seçeneğidir bakalım Bu soruda ne diyor
iç geçiş elementleri ile ilgili iç geçiş
elementleri dediğimiz lantanitler ve
aktinitler di aktinitler çok güzel
tamamı metaldir Evet B grubu
elementlerinin tamamını metal olarak
kabul ediyoruz yani neydi bu işte geçiş
elementleri ve iç geçiş elementleri
hepsini metal olarak kabul ediyoruz
Doğrudur F bloğu elementlerdir Evet iç
geçiş elementleri lantanit ve aktinitler
F bloğ sudur doğru bir ifadedir lantanit
ve aktinit olarak adlandırılan iki
seriden oluşur Doğru bir ifadedir cevap
1 2 3 e seçeneği olacak dostum diyor ki
modern periyodik tablonun genel
özellikleri ile ilgili aşağıdaki
yargılardan hangisi doğrudur diyor her
grupta aynı sayıda element bulunur Hayır
yanlıştır Mesela şöyle göstereyim hemen
periyodik tablomu dönelim şöyle bak 1ci
grupta Ya da 1A grubunda 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
element varken 2ci grupta ne var Bak
görüyor musun 2A grubunda 1 2 3 4 5 6
tane var veya işte 8B Bak 1 2 3 4 tane
var Yani eşit miymiş değilmiş dostum ya
8 B'den 3 tane var da bir tanesine
baktım ben o yüzden Demek ki bu İfade
yanlış her periyotta element sayısı Bir
önceki periyottan daha fazladır diyor
şimdi 1 periyotta 2 element vardı 2
periyotta 8 3 periyotta da 8 Demek ki
eşit olduğu durumlar da varmış gitti
diyor ki her grubun yupak göre
adlandırması a ve b ile adlandırıldığı
ki numarası la aynıdır Hayır değildir 1A
grubuna 1 grup demiştim 2A grubuna 2
grup dedim ama 3A grubuna 13 Grup dedim
neden arada 10 tane B grubu olduğu için
Hatta şöyle de bir şey var 8B grubu 3
taneydi yupak göre 8 grup 9 grup ve 10
grup şeklinde söylüyorduk Demek ki bu
ifade de ne oldu yanlış oldu diyor ki
baş Grup elementleri s ya da p blokta
bulunur doğru söylüyor s ya da P ile
bitiyorsa a grubudur d ya da f ile
bitiyorsa B grubu şeklinde
söyleyebiliriz doğru bir ifadedir biz
doğruyu bulduk bakalım Diyor ki
Mendel'in önerdiği kurala göre
oluşturulmuştur modern periyodik tablo
Moz kine göre yapılmıştır yanlıştır
cevap Ne oldu D seçeneği oldu dostum
bakalım Bu soruda ne diyor p blok
elementleri ile ilgili yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur elektron dağılımı P
orbitar ile biten elementlerin tamamı bu
blokta bulunur E tabii yani P ile
bitiyorsa p bloğu elementidir Doğrudur
periyodik sistemin sağ tarafında yer
alır bak periyodik tabloyu şöyle basit
bir şekilde gösterirsem p' neydi Şurayı
Evet sağ tarafında bulunur doğru bir
ifade proton sayısı en küçük olan
element bu blokta bulunur proton sayısı
en küçük olan hidrojendir hidrojen 1 s
1'dir o da s bloğunda bulunur bu ifade
yanlıştır cevap 1 ve 2 B seçeneği olacak
şimdi gel bakalım periyodik tablodaki o
yer bulmada hangi kurallarımız var şöyle
söylüyoruz önce o Grup numarasını
belirlemek bahsedelim Grup numarası
şöyle belirleniyor dostum eğer s ile
bitiyorsa s'nin üzerindeki sayı kaçsa o
a grubudur mesela Genel olarak
söylüyorum Tabii hidrojen hariç şöyle S1
ile bitiyorsa 1A grubudur S2 ile
bitiyorsa 2A grubudur kim hariç 1 S2
helyumdan grubudur özel durum dostum
eğer P ile bitiyorsa P ile bittiğinde s
ve pdi değerlik orbitalleri değil mi o
zaman SD kileri de toplayacaksın yani P
ile bitiyorsa np ile bitiyorsa Onun
öncesinde kesin bir NS vardır yani şöyle
söyleyeyim 3S 3p hani böyle oluyor ya
bunların üstleri toplamı bu 2'ydi Bunun
üzerinde de a tane var bilmiyorum Artık
bunun Grup numarası şöyle oluyor a + 2A
grubudur tamam mı dostum buradaki a
deyip de kafa karıştırdım x Diyelim x +
2A grubu şeklinde söyleyebiliriz örnek
veriyorum mesela elektron dizilimi P2
ile bitiyorsa Onun öncesinde kesin bir
S2 vardır O yüzden bu 4A grubudur mesela
P5 ile bitiyorsa öncesinde kesin bir S2
vardır O yüzden bu 7A grubudur şeklinde
söylüyoruz dostum eğer d' ile bitiyorsa
B grubu elementidir ve d' ile bitenlerde
olay şudur dostum D ile bittiğinde onun
Öncesinde bir tane Hatta şöyle biraz
yazayım ha n S2 vardır ya da S1 o
değişir Burası da n -1 d şöyle bir şey
var şuraya x şuraya y derim x + Y'ye
göre bulunmaktadır Bu x + Y'ye göre B
grubu olduğu belirleniyor Ama burada da
kurallarımız var Onu detaylıma şöyle Bak
şimdi şurada göstereyim Eğer D1 ile
bitiyorsa Öncesinde bir S2 vardır örnek
veriyorum işte 4 S2 3 D1 gibi üsler
toplamı kaç 3 3B grubudur Eğer D2 ile
bitiyorsa üstler to toplamı 4 olduğu
için 4B grubudur D3 ile bitiyorsa 5B
grubudur dikkat et D4 ile bitemez S1 D5
olurdu S2 D4 yoktu S1 D5 vardı 6b
grubudur eğer S2 D5 ile bitiyorsa 7B
grubudur S2 d6 S2 d7 ve S2 D8
dediğimizde bunların üçü de 8B grubudur
ama normalde hani Grup numarası olarak
Hani yupak göre şöyle i upak He şöyle
yazalım yupak göre bu 3ün grup bu 4 Grup
bu 5 grup bu 6 grup bu 7 grup bu 8 grup
bu 9 Grup Bu da 10 gruptur bunda
herhangi bir sıkıntı yok ama bu B A
şeklinde söylediğimizde bunların üçü de
8B grubudur 8 ile 10 arası 8B grubu D9
ile bitiyor mu e D9 ile bitmezdi ne
oluyordu S1 d10 yapıyorduk topla bunu
kaç etti 11 10 çıkart 1B grubu tamam mı
10un üzerine çıktı mı 10 çıkarıyoruz
Eğer S2 d10 olursa bu da ne olacaktır 2B
grubu olacaktır dostum ha bu da tabii ki
ne oluyor 11 grup Bu da 12 grup şeklinde
söyleniyor ve şöyle bir şey vardır en
büyük Baş kuantum sayısı bak bir dizilim
yazıyorum 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 6 4 S2
3D kaç diyeyim 5 diyeyim mesela sana
burada Grup numarasını sordu D 5 ile
bitiyorsa s ve D'yi topluyorduk 7B grubu
Peki kaçıncı periyot diye sorarsa
kaçıncı periyodu da şöyle buluyorsun en
büyük Baş kuantum sayısı Bak burada 1
var 2 var 3 var 4 var Heh en büyük 4 mü
O zaman bu 4 periyot elementi şeklinde
söylüyorsun Dostum şimdi istersen
örneklere bakalım bak Berilyum diyor 1
S2 2 S2 s ile bitiyorsa direkt s'nin
üzerindeki sayı 2A grubu elementi Ee en
büyük sayı kaç 2 O zaman ne olacaktır 2
periyot elementi şeklinde söylüyoruz
dostum mesela şuna bakalım ne demiş
burada 1 S2 2 S2 2p 5 en büyük sayı 2 2
periyot baştaki O büyük sayılardan
bahsediyorum e p ile bittiğine göre s ve
p'yi topluyoruz kaç etti 7 etti değil mi
Şu son k katmandaki değerlik
elektronlarını topluyorsun hocam Burada
bir tane daha s var Hayır katsayısı aynı
olanları yani P ile bitiyorsa onun hemen
öncesindeki aynı katsayılı s'yi
alıyorsun e topladık kaç gitti 7 s ya da
P ile bitiyorsa a grubuyuz 7A grubu
şeklinde söylüyoruz tekrar
hatırlatıyorum s ya da P ile bitiyorsa
ne diyoruz A grubu elementi diyoruz D
ile bitiyorsa B grubu elementi diyoruz f
ile bitenlere ise zaten Ne diyoruz iç
geçiş elementleri ya da işte ne oluyordu
6 periyot olursa lantanit 7 periyot
olursa aktinit şeklinde söylüyoruz bak
buradaki örnek en en büyük sayı kaç 4
değil mi Hatta Rengi pembe yapalım He en
büyük sayımız 4 o zaman 4 periyot D1 ile
bitmiş D ile bitiyorsa s ve D'yi topla
kaç etti 3 o zaman 3B grubu şeklinde
söylüyoruz ya da 3 grup şeklinde
söylüyoruz Başka bir örnek yapalım
Burada var mesela bak en büyük sayı 4 4
periyot dedik şöyle 4 periyot üsler
toplamı 2 7 daha 9 ha 6 7 Pardon 8 9 10
oldu mu 8B grubu diyorduk ya da işte 4
periyot üsler toplamı 9 9 Grup Bu da
neydi yupak göre adlandırması ydı burada
olmuş d10 la bitmiş H en büyük sayı 4 4
periyot üstler toplamı kaç D ile
bittiğinde s ve D'yi topla 12 10'dan
büyükse 10 çıkart 2B grubu ya da Buna ne
dersin 4 periyot ne olacaktır 12 grup
şeklinde söyleyebiliriz Ha geldi bizim
periyodik tablo burada işte ne olacak
Bak 1 periyotta 1A grubu var ve 8A grubu
var hidrojen ve helyum 2A grubuna geld
Pardon 2 periyoda geldiğimizde burada
işte ne var lityum Berilyum Bor karbon
diye gidiyor işte burada elementler
gözüküyor dikkat ettiysem burada farklı
farklı renkler gösterilmiş buradaki
kahverengimsi renk ne oluyor işte
metaller oluyor burada morla
gösterilenler Ne oldu işte meskem moru
ile gösterilmiş e Bunlar ametaller oldu
yeşille gösterilenler Ne oldu işte yarı
metaller imiz oldu burada turuncuyla
gösterdikleri ise ne olacaktır Tabii ki
Soygazlar mız olacaktır periyodik
tablonun çoğunluğunun metal olduğunu
görmüş olduk şimdi bakalım Bu soruda ne
diyor çekirdeğinde 20 Proton bulunan
nötr x elementinin periyodik sistemdeki
yeri hangisine doğru verilmiştir diyor
Bakalım şimdi 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 6 4
S2 20 bu şekilde yazılıyor en büyük sayı
burada s ile bitiyorsa bunu aldım en
büyük sayı kaç 4 o zaman 4 periyot
nerede var burada var ve burada var ve s
ile bitiyorsa s'nin üzerindeki sayı s
ile bitiyorsa A grubu s'nin üzerindeki
sayı 2 2A grubu cevap da ne olacaktır e
seçeneği olacaktır şuna bakalım Diyor ki
elektron dağılımı P2 ile biten 3 P2 ile
biten nötr x elementinin periyodik
tablodaki yeri P ile bitiyorsa ne
oluyordu öncesinde kesin bir s vardı e
topla kaç etti 4 P ile bittiğine göre A
grubu elementi en büyük sayı kaç 3 o
zaman 3 periyot 4A grubu dersin 3
periyot 4A burada İstersen yazayım 1 S 2
2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 2 gördün mü en büyük
sayı 3 3 3 periyot P ile bittiğine göre
s ve p'yi topladık 4A grubu şeklinde
söyledik buna bakalım Diyor ki demir
metalinin periyodik tablodaki yerini
soruyormuş yazalım şimdi önce periyodik
tablodaki dizilimini yapalım da elektron
dizilimini 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 3 P6 4 S2
3D 6 oldu en büyük sayı kaç 4 4 periyot
D ile bitiyorsa B grubu aı bir ele bir
kere B grubu e toplamı kaç 2 6 daha 8 8
9 10 olduğunda toplamları Ne diyorduk 8B
grubu diyorduk O zaman cevap Ne oldu D
seçeneği oldu burada bana yupak yupak
göre şeyi vermiş bak grupları 1ci grup
2ci grup 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 ne gidiyor
işte 18'e kadar gidiyor diyor ki
alüminyum elementinin periyodik
tablodaki Neyi sistemdeki periyod ve
grup numarası sırasıyla nedir diye
soruyor Hım bakalım şimdi alüminyum 13 1
S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 3 P1 olacaktır en
büyük sayı 3 3ün periyot olacak yani 3
3'ü aldık çok güzel bir de burada var E
şimdi ne s ile p'yi topladık 3A grubu 3A
grubu şurada gösteriliyordu 13 grup
olarak söyleniyordu O zaman cevap Ne
oldu a seçeneği oldu hazır şurada bir
boşluk var Onu da göstermiş olayım Bak
şöyle bir şey var S1 ile bitti 1A S2 ile
bitti 2A P1 ile bitti 3A ya da 13 Grup
bunlar 1ci grup ve 2in grup sonra P2 ile
bitti 4A grubu 14 Grup P3 ile bitti 5A
grubu 15 grup p4 ile bitti 6a grubu 16
grup P5 ile bitti 7A grubu 17 grup ve P6
ile bitti 8A grubu 18 Grup diyoruz tek
istisnayı da 1 S2 de söyleyelim bu 1
periyot 8A grubu elementidir soygaz
Çünkü hocam değerlik elektron sayısı 2
olanların hepsi 2A grubunda mıdır Hayır
burada helyum 8A grubundadır o zaman 8A
grubundakiler in hepsinin değerlik
elektron sayısı 8 midir Hayır helyumun K
2'dir Gördüğün gibi helyum hep
istisnadır sakın unutma bunu şuraya
bakalım Diyor ki Klor elementi için
yargılarından hangileri doğrudur önce
bir elektron dizilimini yazalım 1 S2 2
S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P5 oldu çok güzel diyor
ki magnezyumla aynı periyottadır bakalım
1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 12'yi yazacağım 3 S2 ha
Bu da 3 periyot Bu da 3 periyot Evet
ikisi de aynı periyot Adır doğru diyor
ki flor ile aynı gruptadır floru yazalım
1 S2 2 S2 2 P5 Aha S2 P5 S2 B5 İkisi de
7A grubu aynı gruptadır doğru bir ifade
1 ve 2 doğru diyor ki potasyum ile
farklı periyot ve farklı gruptadır
yazalım onu da 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P6
4 S1 oldu Aha 4 periyot periyotları
farklı 1A grubu e grupları da farklı
Yani bu ifade de neymiş doğruymuş Cevap
e seçeneği olacak dostum Bu soruda Ne
diyor bakalım Yukarıdaki periyodik
sistemde yer alan element atomları ile
ilgili aşağıdaki ifadelerden hangisi
yanlıştır şurası 1A grubu değil mi
şurası 2A grubu sonra 3B 4B 5B 6b 7B
sonra 3 tane 8B grubu var burada yazdım
sonra 1B ve 2B grupları var Sonra 3A
geliyor 4A 5A 6a 7A ve 8A grupları Peki
bunları yazdık diyor ki hangisi
yanlıştır X'in değerlik elektron sayısı
1'dir ya Ne oldu S1 ile bitmesi
gerekmiyor mu 1A grubundakilerin e s ile
bittiğinde değerlik orbitali sdi
üstündeki sayı da değerlik elektron
sayısıyla yer alır Evet Gördüğün gibi 2A
grubunda yer alır Doğrudur X ve z aynı
periyottadır diyor Bakalım X ve z Evet
ikisi de 3üncü mü ne ikinci periyottan
mış O yüzden Doğrudur yupak göre Grup
numara en büyük olan TD diyor yupak göre
bakalım 3 grup 4 Grup 5 grup 6 grup 7
grup 8 grup oluyor bu e Buraya bakarsak
Z ise 6a grubu 16 grup oluyor en büyük
olan ZM miş Demek ki bu yanlış diyor ki
Z'nin elektron dizilimi şudur diyor e
bakalım 1 2 periyot şurası 2 periyot 6a
Grubu 2 periyot 6a grubunu yazarsak Eğer
p4 ile bitmesi lazım 6a Grubu 2 periyot
dediği için 2 p4 ile bitmeli o zaman 1
S2 2 S2 2 p4 yani doğruymuş cevap Ne
oldu burada yanlışı bulduk D seçeneği
hocam burada Z'yi şey yaparak sayarak
bulamaz mıydık bulurdun Şöyle 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 88'i yazdığında zaten karşına bu
çıkacaktır atom numarasına göre
yazılıyor ya oradan yakalayabilirsin
şimdi bak periyodik tablomuz da bilmemiz
gerekenler 1A grubuna alkali metaller
diyoruz kim hariç hidrojen hariç
hidrojen ametal sakın unutma 1A
grubundadır ama metaldir yani o
gruptakilerin özelliklerini göstermez
burada 2A grubuna Toprak alkali metali
diyoruz Yani şöyle S1 ile bitenlerin
Hepsi metaldir yanlış hidrojen 1 S 1'dir
ve metaldir Bunu sakın unutma 1 S1
ametal dedi ki buranın 2A grubu S2 ile
bitenler S2 ile bitenlerin hepsi Toprak
alkali metaldir Hayır şurada kim var
helyum var 1 S2 ile biter ama nedir soy
gazdır Yani buradan da bunu yakalamış
oluruz veya S2 ile bitenlerin hepsi 2A
grubundadır Hayır 1 S2 helyumdan
grubundadır istisnaların sakın unutma
sonra arada geliyor işte 3B 4B 5B diye
gidiyor işte B grupları var Sonra 3A
grubu B gruplarının hepsine geçiş
metalleri diyoruz ya da geçiş
elementleri 3A grubuna Toprak metalleri
ismini veriyoruz sonra Normalde 4A
karbon grubu 5A azot grubu 6a ise
kalkojenler deniyor da müfredatta yok o
yüzden üzerinde durmuyorum 7A grubuna
halojenler asit yapabilenler
anlamındadır ve 8A grubuna ise Soygazlar
asal gazlar ismini veriyoruz mesela
Bunlar da şöyledir P6 ile bitmektedir
yani Soygazların hepsinde elektron
dizilimi P6 ile biter yine helyum hariç
Gördüğün gibi o istisnayı unutma
Normalde 8A grubu değerlik elektron
sayısı 8'dir A grupların öyle güzel
tarafı var yani değerlik elektron
sayısıyla Grup numarası aynı oluyor yani
tabii ki hangisine A grubu B grubu
ismiyle söylüyorum 1 A grubu S1 ile
bitiyor değerlik elektron sayısı 1 grup
numarası da 1A e S2 işte 2A grubu
değerlik elektron sayısı da 2 3a grubu
P1 ile bitiyor s ve p'yi topla üstler
toplamı 3 3A grubu yani değerlik
elektron sayısı 3A grubu aynı oluyor
değil mi oradan bu şekilde yakal
yakalayabilirsin sadece istisnai olan
helyumdan grubunda bulunur özel durumdur
sakın unutma bunu burada Mesela 7A grubu
var Bu neyle bitiyor P5 ile bitiyor 6a
grubu p4 ile bitiyor 5A grubu P3 ile
bitiyor hep önüne 2i ekliyorsun Çünkü s
var ya öncesinde E bu ne olacaktır P2
ile bitecektir Bu da P1 ile bitecektir
Şunları da yazalım 3B grubu ne ile
bitiyor D1 ile bitiyor 4B grubu D2 ile
bitiyor 5B grubu D3 ile bitiyor 6b grubu
D4 ile bitmiyor s D5 ile bitiyor değil
mi D4 yok unut bunu bu ne D5 ile bitiyor
S2 D5 buaya geldik S2 d6 buna geldik S2
d7 şuna geldik S2 D8 şurası D9 yoktu S1
d10 Bu da ne olacaktır S2 d10 şeklinde
olacaktır dostum Bak burası önemlidir
şöyle bence fotoğrafını çekmek
istiyorsan çek Ben de bekliyorum aşağısı
var Bak görüyor musun burada işte neler
vardı F bloğu vardı şurada akiler 4F ile
bitenler Buradakiler de 5f ile bitenler
Ama tabii ki bu 6 periyot şu da 7
periyot şeklinde söylüyoruz Şimdi
istersen grupların özelliklerinden
bahsedelim mesela 1A grubu dediğimizde
hidrojen hariç alkali metallerdir
diyoruz grubun özel adı alkali metaller
kim hariç hidrojen hariç S1 ile
bitmektedir değerlik elektron sayıları
1'dir hidrojen hariç hepsi metaldir
hidrojen metaldir dedik bileşik
oluştururken genel olarak daha doğrusu
alkali metal olanlar yani şunlar bir
elektron verir yani bileşiklerinde + 1
yüklü olma eğilimindedirler ama hidrojen
-1 de alabilir + 1 de alabilir Hatta
şöyle söyleyelim hidrojen daima + 1 alır
diye bir şey söylerlerse size şunu
yazarlar yok ya yanlış anlama Yok yok
Onu kastetmiyorum hidrojen burada sodyum
+ 1 ya hidrojen -1 de alabiliyor O
yüzden yazdım bunu yanlış bir şey
anlaşılmasın buradan yani ne diyoruz
hidrojen -1 de alabiliyor + 1 de
alabiliyor ama diğer 1A grubu
elementleri sadece + 1 al olabiliyor
tamam mı dostum Başka ne diyoruz işte
grupta aşağıya doğru metalik aktiflik
artar metalik aktiflik ne olacaktır işte
burada fransiyum inki en büyüktür
şeklinde söyleyebiliriz Bunlar çok
isteklidir reaksiyona girmeye o kadar
isteklidir ki şöyle söyleyeyim mesela
sodyum suya atıyorsun güm diye patlıyor
yani bayağı bir şiddetli patlıyor Hatta
Eee sodyumun suyla tepkimesi çok
fazladır en aktif metaller 1A grubunda
bulunur diyebiliriz dostum tamam mı Yani
çok aktifler suyla çok hızlı Reaksiyon
verirler mesela potasyum daha da hızlı
Reaksiyon veriyor yani aktiflikleri
arttıkça ne oluyor Reaksiyon verme
hızları da artıyor bazen şiddeti de
artıyor sezyum Mesela yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam bir deney yapmışlardı
Bununla ilgili küveti patlatıyor yani
bayağı bir şiddetli patlıyor O yüzden
bir A grubu elementlerini doğada böyle
metal halinde bulamazsın hep bileşik
yapmak ister boşta bir şey gördü mü Aha
oksijen deyip hemen bileşik yapar o
bileşik oksit halinde Şu halinde bu
halinde yani bileşik halinde bulunur
Mesela sodyumu nasıl buluyorsun tuz
şeklinde bulunuyorsun değil mi sofra
tuzu şeklinde buluyorsun mesela sodyum
metalinin Öyle bir özelliği var
kestiğinde böyle parlaktır da dur bekle
Sodyum metali diyorsam Aha bende var
Yani şöyle açmam lazım tabii de HH şöyle
açtım mesela şunun içerisinde
çıkaramadım şurada Mesela lan
çıkaramıyorum dur açıp göstereceğim ya
Ne olacak sanki Bak mesela bu Sodyum
metali şöyle yakından göstereyim sana ve
daha ilginç bir şey yapacağım bak şöyle
kesiyorum bu bıçakla bile kesilebilen
bir metaldir şöyle kesip sana lan
gösteremedim dur L hemen oksitleniyor Ya
dur Evet Bak şu parlaklığa bak Görüyor
musun bak şu an parlak yavaş yavaş
matlaşıyor şimdi şimdi o parlaklığını
göstermek için şöyle Sallıyorum Şimdi
matlaştı neden havanın oksijeni ile
hemen reaksiyona girme isteğinde hemen
daha fazla oksitlenmek şöyle kapatayım
da şey yapayım kurtulalım Ondan sonra
ben bir elimi yıkayıp hemen hızlıca
devam edeceğim şimdi şunu diyor
olabilirsin hocam suya atıp patlatsana
He oldu Bir de buraları yakayım değil mi
olmaz evin içerisinde olacak şey değil
dışarıda yapılan deney de zaten
göstermiştim onları yani ve hatta eski
videolarımda vardı Onunla ilgili bir şey
suya atıyorum bayağı şiddetli bir
şekilde patlıyor ona da oradan
bakabilirsin burada yapmam yani kusura
bakma Evet devam ediyorum Isı ve
elektriği iletirler ya metal iletmeye ÇK
mi metal olduğu için iletir pillerin
yapısında bulur lityum iyon pil diyoruz
değil mi mesela Oradan aklında kalsın
erime noktaları yoğunlukları düşüktür
yumuşak metallerdir Mesela işte gördün
sodyum ne yaptı kesilebiliyor yani ufak
bir bıçak darbesiyle bile kesebiliyor
böyle koparabilir yumuşaktır Eee o
yüzden çok kolay bir şekilde kesilebilir
suyla şiddetli reaksiyona girerler
bayağı bir şiddetli reaksiyona girerler
işte gruptaki metallerin oksit ve
hidroksitleri de bazik özellik gösterir
yani buradaki şeyler metaller nasıl
söyleyeyim sana bazik yapılıdır dah
metallerin özelliği yani metaller bazik
karakterlidir oksitleri de hidroksitleri
de baziktir Mesela şöyle söyleyeyim
naoh var bak b
koh var baz Bunlar işte bak ne var
sodyum potasyum değil mi bunlar na2o Bu
da bazik bir yapıya sahiptir veya k2o
Bunlar da bazik yapıya sahiptir suya
atılırsa ortamın PH değeri ne olur 7'nin
üzerine çıkar oda sıcaklığında Burada da
gösteriyor bak sodyumu göstermiş lityumu
potasyumu fransiyum fransiyumun burada
bileşiği şeklinde göstermiş Çünkü
radyoaktif bir maddedir öyle hani olup
da ortalık yerde sana gösterebileceğim
bir durumda değil 2A grubuna
geldiğimizde bunların da elektron
dizilimi S2 ile bitmekte ir ama her S2
ile biten 2A grubunda mıdır Hayır neydi
helyum hariç değerlik elektron sayıları
2'dir Buradakilerin ama her değerlik
elektron sayısı 2 olan nerede olmuyordu
2A grubunda olmuyordu Bundan dolayı da
bunu da bilmek lazım diyor ki grubun
özel adı Toprak alkali metallerdir 1A
grubuna alkali metal 2A grubuna Toprak
alkali metaller ismini veriyoruz tamamı
metaldir burada istisnası yoktur
bileşiklerinde + 2 yükseltgenme
basamağına sahiptirler Yani iki elektron
vererek bileşik oluşturmaya yatkındırlar
çok aktif metallerdir ama 1A grubundan
daha pasifler genel olarak doğada
bileşik halinde bulunmaktadırlar mesela
kalsiyumu böyle doğada kalsiyum şeklinde
bulamazsın Kalsiyum karbonat kireç
şeklinde falan bulabilirsin kalsiyum
oksit şeklinde bulabilirsin alkali
metallere göre aktiflikleri daha düşük
ama yine de aktif metallerdir onu
söylememiz lazım su ile tepkimesinden
yine Hidrojen gazı oluştururlar burada
Berilyum hariç diyoruz Çünkü Berilyum
amfoter özelliktedir su ile tepkime
vermiyor oda koşullarında tamamı katı
halde bulunmaktadır Isı ve elektriği
iletirler metal Sonuçta e par lak tırlar
metal olduğu için bunu hep
söyleyebilirsin Berilyum hariç oksit ve
hidroksitleri yine baziktir burada
Mesela magnezyum oksiti vermiş tepkimeye
giriyor mesela magnezyum hidroksit
vardır Bu Mide yanmasında Midem çok
yanıyor falan tabletler var ya işte
onlarda magnezyum hidroksit var mesela
bazik yapıya sahip attığında ne oluyor
midenin ph'ını yukarı çıkartıyor ve
rahatlatıyor seni 3A grubunun özel ismi
Toprak metallerdir ki elektron dizilimi
P1 ile biter ns2 np1 şeklinde değerlik
elektron sayısı da 3'tür bak 2 ve 1 daha
Toplam 3 ediyor ya buradan geliyor
bileşiklerinde ne alıyor + 3
yükseltgenme basamağına sahip oluyorlar
gruptaki Bor elementi yarım metaldir
diğerleri metaldir dostum ve od da
koşullarında katı halde bulunurlar 1A ve
2 A'ya göre daha pasiftir 1A ve 2A grubu
daha aktif metaldir onu söyleyelim bak
Burada bir tane örneğimiz var diyor ki
ifadelerinden hangileri doğrudur bana
elementleri vermiş x demiş 3 yani 1 S2 2
S1 y demiş 4 1 S2 2 S2 Bir de Z demiş 5
1 S2 2 s 2 2p 1 2 periyotta bu 1A grubu
elementi bu 2A grubu elementi Bu da 3A
grubu elementi bakalım Diyor ki x Isı ve
elektriği iyi iletir e metaldir 1A grubu
metalleri Isı ve elektriği iyi iletir
Doğrudur y doğada saf olarak elementel
halde bulunur ne demiştik 2A grubu
elementleri doğada saf halde
bulunmuyordu bileşik halinde bulunuyordu
gitti Z oda koşullarında katı halde
bulunur 3A grubu elementleri katı halde
bulunuyordu doğru bir ifadeyi cevap da
ne olacaktır C seçeneği olak olır 7A
grubuna geldik bunlara halojenler
diyoruz ns2 np5 ile bitiyordu e burada
Mesela bak ilginç bir örneği vardır Onu
yazayım İlginç değil de bilmen gereken
bir örnek 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3 P6 4 Z2
3D 10 4 P5 Bak bu bromur brom 35 şimdi
diyebilirsin ya hocam E tamam p var çok
güzel ama öncesinde D var ama s de var
bak 4'le olan bak En S2 np5 işte P ile
bitiyorsa bunları alıyorsun dostum
bunların toplamı 7 O yüzden 7A grubu P5
de bitiyorsa 7A grubu şimdi değerlik
elektron sayıları 7'dir Eyvallah
gruptakiler genel olarak metaldir
Aşağıdakilerin bir yarım metal özelliği
olduğu söylenebilir ama yukarıya doğru
ametalik aktiflik artmaktadır onu
söyleyelim flor Klor brom iyot Bunlar
ametal astatin ve tenesin tenesin de
böyle yar şeydir bu yapay bir element de
yani yarı metal olarak kabul görüyor Şu
anda kabul kabul ediliyor söyleyeyim
yani astatin bile aynıdır yani yarı
metal demeye böyle çok da dili varmıyor
insanın böyle özellikleri değişken O
yüzden astatin ve tenesin işte yarı
metal diyorum sadece zaten çok da bilmen
gerekmiyor onu da söyleyeyim Bunlar
metallerle iyonik bağlı bileşik yapar
Sonuçta ametal metalle iyonik bileşik
yapar kalsiyum metal flor ametal Al sana
iyonik bileşik Ama ametallerle mesela
burada farklı bileşikler yapmış görüyor
musun Yani bunlar hem metallerle
tepkimeye giriyor hem de ametallerle
tepkimeye girebiliyor Çünkü metaller
ametaller tepkimeye girer ametal
ametalle de tepkimeye girer mesela HC
oluşturmuş bu asit de hatırlarsan Aynı
gruptaki bak iyot ve flor bileşik
oluşturabiliyor böyle ilginç
elementlerdir Yani hem metal hem
ametallerle tepkime
verebilmektedirler oluşuyor
bileşiklerinde flor hariç şöyle
söyleyeyim flor sadece -1 alır önemli
bir ayrıntıdır sadece -1 yükseltgenme
basamağına kim flor sahip gruptaki diğer
var ya Klor brom iyot Bunlar -1 ile + 7
arasında farklı değişken değerlikler
alabilmektedirler onu söyleyelim Bunlar
dedik yai Halojen asit yapabilen
anlamında hidrojenli bileşikleri asit
özelliği gösterir mesela üstüne yazalım
hcl HF sonra H BR h ı Bunlar işte neydi
asit değil mi dostum ve oda koşullarında
şöyle söyleyeyim flor gaz halinde
bulunur Klor da gaz halinde bulunur brom
sıvı halde bulunur iyot asetin tenesin
bunları da katı olarak söylüyoruz dostum
8 A grubu asal gazlar ya da Soygazlar
dediğimiz gruptur ns2 np6 ile
bitmektedir kim hariç helyum hariç
helyum ns2 ile bitmekte 1 S2 ile
bitmekte Ama onun dışındakiler P6 ile
bitmektedir değerlik elektron sayısı
helyumun 2 diğerlerin ki 8'dir tek
atomlu gaz halinde bulunurlar bak çok
önemli bir ifadedir Eğer moleküler gaz
diyorsa Bunlar ametal Ama tek atomlu gaz
diyorsa Bunlar soygazdan tamam mı Başka
Bunlar bileşik oluşturmazlar tüm
orbitalleri tam dolu olduğu için bileşik
yapmak istemezler karar lı dırlar diğer
atomlar bunlara benzemeye çalışır Öyle
böyle artistler dirir de yani şöyle bir
şey var bileşik oluşturmaz diyoruz da
çok özel şartlarda xenonun yani şunun
bileşikleri oluyor ama çok
zorlamanın bir şey değil çok zorlayıcı
şartlarda bileşik oluşturulduğu var Ama
genel olarak biz ne diyoruz Soygazlar
bileşik yapmaz diyoruz erime ve kaynama
noktaları düşüktür Hocam niye ya gaz
diyorsun ya gaz gaz gazsa erime kaynama
noktası düşük değil mi Tabii ki öyledir
başka Bunlar ışıklandırma sistemlerinde
k kullanmakta mesela helyum İşte bu
florasanlı falan kullanılıyor neon
Işıklar vardır mesela neon böyle
tabelalar vardır Orada mesela
kullanılıyor Argon mesela ampullerde çok
kullanılıyordu E kripton yine
kullanılıyor Zenon bak Xenon Zenon
farlar aklında olsun bu bizim şeyler
vardır böyle Eee nasıl ifade edeyim e
kekolar vardır e kekolar böyle şey yapar
arabaları aşırı böyle faça yapmayı Çaça
yapmayı severler böyle bilirsin bu Bazı
yerlerde de hani tam meraka bir şey
demiyorum da gürültüyle geçenlere Ben
diyorum genel olarak böyle da da da
da basarak böyle işte egzoz patlatarak
falan gidenler var ya onlara birazcık
kek oluyor işte arabayı alıyor Doğan
görünümlü şey a alıyor arabayı Mesela
işte farları zenon far yaptırdım Aa
diyor işte Aa bir gidiyor yolda diyor
şöyle işte egzozu patlattım bunu yaptım
arabayı yere yaklaştırdı falan araba
kendinden geçmiş böyle o gidiyor işte o
zenon far var ya bir yakıyor arkadaki
şey adam veya Karşıdan Gelen Adam far
görmüş tavşan gibi kalıyor Mesela işte
çok yüksek Işık veriyor zenon far da
işte yani ksenon fır e ksenon da nedir
bir
soygazdan olduğuna karar vererek bir
çıkışa Ulaş diyor hangi çıkışa ulaşırsın
diyor Diyor ki 1A ve 2A grubu
elementleri bileşiklerinde pozitif ve
negatif değere sahip Hoppa burada
negatif değere sahip olabilir burada
hidrojeni düşünebiliriz değil mi
hidrojeni düşünürsek olur ama 1A ve 2A
grubu hepsinde böyle bir şey var mı
bileşiklerinde yok sadece hidrojende
böyle bir durum var ama diğerlerinde yok
o yüzden bunu ne yaptık eledik gitti O
zaman yanlış olduğu için buraya geldim
çok güzel Devam ediyorum periyodik
sistemin 17 grubu yani 7A grubu
elementleri halojenler Evet doğrudur
3üncü çıkışa geldim E buradaki şu boş
soruyu da halledelim değil mi geçiş
elementlerinin tamamı oda koşullarında
katı halde bulunur Evet diyor ki geçiş
katı halde bulunur bir tanesi hariç oda
koşullarında cıva geçiş elementidir ve
sıvı halde bulunur yanlıştır mesela
burada da buna çıkardık ama biz Neyse
çıkışı takip ettiğimizde 3 numaraya
çıkmış olduk bakalım buradaki sorumuz da
ne diyor Yukarıdaki ifadelerden
hangileri tüm F ve D Blok elementleri
için doğrudur F ve D hepsi metaldir bunu
kafadan doğru olarak işaretle oda
koşullarında katı halde bulunur cıva
sıvı halde bulunuyordu O yüzden bunu
eledik bileşiklerinde pozitif
yükseltgenme basamaklarına sahipleri
metal oldukları için doğru bir ifadedir
cevabımız da ne oldu C seçeneği oldu
burada bakalım ne diyor ifadelerinden
hangileri doğrudur diyor x vermiş 2 yani
1 S2 y demiş 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S2 a İkisi
de S2 ile bitiyor değerlik elektron
sayısı bunun da 2'dir bunun da 2'dir
değerlik elektron sayıları eşittir doğru
Aynı gruptadır yanlış Bu neydi 8A grubu
bu 2A grubuyuz helyum özel durum sakın
unutma oda koşullarında bu ne helyum
soygaz gaz halinde bulunur y ise 2A
grubunda metal katı halde bulunur
Doğrudur cevabımız ne olacaktır 1 ve 3
olacaktır C seçeneği unutmaman gereken
şy şu oda koşullarında yani 25 derecede
Sıvı halde bulunan bir tane metal vardır
O da cadır geri kalan katı halde bulunur
CIA da geçiş metalidir yani B grubu
elementidir Bunlar unutmaman gereken
bilgiler buraya geldik Bakalım ne diyor
elektron dizilimi aşağıdaki gibi
sonlanan elementlerden hangisi oda
koşullarında gaz halinde bulunamaz h h
Hım E bu 1 S1 hidrojen gaz halinde
bulunur E ne 3 P6 P6 ile bitiyorsa 8A
grubu elementidir şöyle bak 1 S2 2 S2 2
P6 3S 2 3 P6 8A grubu soygaz gaz halinde
bulunacaktır gaz halinde bulunamaz
soruyor 1 2'yi eledik P2 diyor bak 1 S2
2 S2 2 P2 E bu nedir 4A grubu karbondan
bahsediyor karbon oda koşullarında katı
haldedir gaz halinde bulunmaz Doğru E bu
ne 1 S2 2 S2 2p 4 6a grubu 6a grubunun
ilk üyesi Kimdi bu oksijendir oksijen
gaz halinde bulunur E bu ne 3 P5 1 S2 2
S2 2 P6 3 S2 3 P5 E bu da 17 klordan
bahsediyor e Klor gaz halinde bulunur Bu
da ne oldu gitti biz cevabı bulduk
cevabımız Ne oldu C seçeneği oldu burada
K yazdığıma bakma yani karbondan
bahsediyorum o yüzden öyle yazdım ama
katı halde bulunur onu da belirtmiş
olalım Burada şunu söyleyeyim dostum ilk
20 element var ya bunların kim olduğunu
bileceksin yani 1 hidrojen 2 helyum 3
işte lityum 4 Berilyum bunların hepsini
bileceksin dostum Hatta işte Neydi bu p4
ile bitmiş değil mi kaç oluyor 8 işte
oksijen değil mi 6 A grubunda oksijen
var E oksijen olduğuna göre oksijen gaz
halindedir Yani bunların hepsini bilmen
lazım ilk 20 element önemli şimdi şu
sorumuza bakalım Diyor ki elektron
dizilimleri yukarıda verilen
elementlerle ilgili yargılarından
hangileri doğrudur diyor Hım burada ne
olmuş 3 S2 3 P6 3 periyot 8A grubu
elementi diye yazdık ikincisi ne olmuş 3
S2 s ile bitiyorsa direkt s'yi alıyorduk
en büyük sayı 3 3 periyot 1A grubu E
buraya geldiğimizde s ile bitmiş 2
periyot yazdık ne olacak 2A grubu
elementi olacak dostum diyor ki elektron
dizilimleri verilenlerle ilgili
hangileri doğrudur diyor ki x atomu
kararlı yapısından dolayı bileşik
oluşturmaz 8A grubu olduğu için doğru
bir ifadedir y elementi su ile şiddetli
tepkime verir 3 periyot 1A grubu 1A
grubu metalleri su ile şiddetli tepkime
veriyordu doğru bir ifadedir Z oda
koşullarında katı halde bulunur 2A grupu
elementlerinin hepsi katı halde
bulunuyordu doğru bir ifadedir cevap 1 2
3 e seçeneği olacak dostum Bu sorumuz da
diyor ki elektron dizilimi n s üzeri a
ile sonlanan element atomu ile ilgili
olarak ya s ile sonlanıyor mu s ile
sonlanıyor ola s bloğu elementidir
Doğrudur bulunduğu periyotta metalik
aktifliği en yüksek olan elementtir
kesin değil S1 ile bitiyorsa 1A grubudur
en aktif odur S2 ile bitiyorsa O da
aktiftir ama 1 A'dan daha pasiftir o
yüzden a değerini bilmediğim için
Bununla ilgili kesin bir şey söyleyemem
gitti diyor ki elektriği iletir ya s ile
bitiyor mu çok güzel yani ya 1A ya 2A
gibi düşünüyorsun da şöyle bir şey var 1
S2 ihtimali yok mu var Yani bunun soygaz
olma ihtimali de var helyum olma
ihtimalinden dolayı yani elektriği ileti
de kesin değil ne olacaktır cevabımız
Yalnız bir a seçeneği olacaktır bakalım
bu sorumuz ne diyor elementlerden
hangisinin karşısındaki bilgi yanlıştır
diyor hidrojen hidrojen 1 S 1'di 1A
grubu
elementiyle bileşiklerinde -1 veya + 1
alabiliyordu O yüzden birincisi doğru
bakır diyor 2 9 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 6
4 S2 3D 9 değildi 4S 1 3D 10D E bir
dakika üsler toplamı kaç 11 d ile
bittiği için B grubu 11 olduğu için 10
çıkart 1 B grubu 4 periyot ne oldu 1 B
grubu D ile bittiği için D Blok elementi
zaten buna Hiç uğraşmaya da gerek yokmuş
doğruymuş S'ye bakalım bulunduğu grupta
atom numarası En küçük olan elementtir
diyor Allah Allah Hemen yazalım 1 S2 2
S2 2p 6 3 S2 3p 4'tür bu E bir dakika
Aynı grupta 1 S2 2 S2 2 p4 de var yani
En küçük olan budur yani bu İfade yanlış
oldu devam ediyorum lityum diyor alkali
metaldir 1 S2 2 S1 S1 ile bitiyorsa 1A
Grubu 2 S1 ile bittiği için 2 periyot 1A
grubu E bu da metaldir ve alkali
metaldir Doğrudur Bakalım burada ne
diyor kalsiyum diyor 1 S2 2 S2 2p 6 3 S2
3p 6 4 S2 2A grubu elementi metaldir e
katı halde elektriği iletir doğru bir
ifadedir biz yanlışı bulduk cevabımız C
seçeneğidir burada ne vermiş bak 1A
grubu 2A grubu gidiyor Burası 3A grubu
4A 5A 6a 7A ve 8A grubu şeklinde
belirttik diyor ki Yukarıdaki periyodik
sistemde yerleri belirtilen element
atomları ile ilgili aşağıdaki
ifadelerden hangisi yanlıştır diye
soruyor diyor ki X ve Y metal t
metaldir diyor hım hım hım şimdi şurada
bir Merdiven var bak şu merdiven
merdiven metalle ametal ayıran bir
merdivendir bu merdivende şöyle bir
durum söz konusudur dostum tam şu
merdiven hizasında olanlar vardır şunlar
şöyle şöyle oradaki var mıydı Evet yoktu
o Pardon şöyle He şunlar şöyle şöyle bu
merdiven hizasındaki metalde Bundan
dolayı T burada yarı metal olacaktır
ametal değildir X ve Y metaldir diyor
Evet bu da metaldir bu Bu da şeyin
merdivenin altında kaldığı için metaldir
ama T ametal değil yarı metal olması
gerektiği için bu İfade yanlış oldu
diyor ki X'in elektron dizilimi s ile
sonlanır ya 1A grubu elementi değil mi 1
2 3 periyot 1A yani 1 S2 2 S2 2 P6 3 S
1'dir S ile sonlanır Doğrudur hiç
uğraşmama da gerek yoktu 1A grubu S1 ile
bitiyor değil mi diyor ki Z
halojenden doğru bir ifadedir diyor ki K
ve T benzer kimyasal özelliğe sahiptir
aynı gruptakiler şöyle çizersek Eğer
benzer özellikleri var mıdır ya olabilir
söyleyebiliriz bunu sonuçta yani kesin
yanlıştır şeklinde değil de benzer
özellikleri olabilir söyleriz diyor ki X
ve Y elektriği iletir e metaller
elektriği iletir Doğrudur cevap Ne oldu
a seçeneği oldu dostum buradaki soruda
diyor ki periyodik sistemde 6 periyotta
bulunan bir element ile ilgili 6
periyotta bulunuyor H Hım Bakalım
hangileri Doğru olabilir değerlik
elektron sayısı 3'tür 6 periyot 3A 6
periyot 3B Olamaz mı olabilir değerlik
elektron sayısı 3 olabilirmiş F blokta
bulunur e 6 periyotta lantanitler vardı
o yüzden burada bulunamaz mı Olabilir
değil mi 6 periyot dediği için olur
aktinit serisinde bir dakika aktinit
serisi 7 periyottadır O yüzden Ne oldu
şöyle yazalım periyot bu olmadı cevap 1
ve 2 olacaktır B seçeneği bana burada
elementlerin sembolleri ile birlikte
gösterimini vermiş Periyodik tabloda
diyor ki ifadelerinden hangisi yanlıştır
şurası 1A grubu şurası bakalım 3A grubu
şu aktinit
aktinitler şurası bakalım 3B 4B 5B 6b 7B
8B 8B Bu da 8B şu 1B 2B de bu Heh yazdık
diyor ki D bloktaki element sayısı en
fazladır 1 2 3 4 bu tarafta 10 40
element oluyor ya burada 30 var burada
daha az var Evet en fazla olan kimmiş D
blokmar koşullarında katı halde bulunur
diyor verilen elementlere bakarsak Eğer
potasyum var katı Uranyum katı nikel
katı çinko kı Bor katı O yüzden Doğrudur
diyor ki s ve D bloktaki elementler aynı
periyottadır bakalım SD ki bu 4 periyot
D'deki bunlar bunlar da 4 periyot
Doğrudur diyor ki nikel 9B grubudur
Hayır yanlıştır burada 8B grubundadır
Hatta şöyle neydi 3B 4B 5B 6b 7B 8B 8B
8B E zaten 8 B'nin sonuncusu hadi
diyelim yupak göre söylese 10 grup ol
olur yani 9B kafadan yanlış bir ifadedir
Uranyum aktinitler serisindendir doğru
cevap Ne oldu D seçeneği oldu dostum
Seni bilmem ama ben birazcık yoruldum
açıkçası bayağı bir şey anlattık çok
önemli yerlerden bahsettik bak Nelerden
bahsettik periyodik tablodaki yer
bulmadan bahsettik periyodik tabloyu
şöyle bir tanıdık grupların
özelliklerinden bahsettik grupların özel
isimlerinden bahsettik burayı sağlam bir
şekilde tekrar etmeni rica ediyorum
senden soru çözmeyi de sakın unutma ogem
materyalden MEB kitabından oradaki
soruları sakın ihmal etme Benim soru
çözümü de bak bakabilirsin dostum onları
da yayınlayacağım zaten beni dinlediğin
için teşekkür ediyorum Ne diyoruz iki
fosfor bir asit kimya Bu kadar basit şu
kanala abone olma işini de halledersin
çok mutlu olurum görüşmek üzere